we're getting through there you know i
didn't realize we're going on quite long
i expected this to go long but um
yeah i really want to get through
everything in one shot order flow
sequencing
order flow sequencing where is my chart
so you can see areas in here right like
this
okay 1 2 11 14 22
and there's going to be bullish version
of sequencing right here
10 16 45 61 69
right bearish bullish right and in the
settings
go to indicator uh
give it a second to come up order flow
sequencing right here all right you
could set the cluster size how many five
because that's a three
five is is strong three is you know
again depending on the market you're
trading you know if you're using a four
range chart you might want to set it to
three but five is quite strong
i use five for pretty much all markets
unless i'm looking at a four range chart
in the bonds or ten years i'll change it
to three
and it's going to be bullish it's going
to be cyan and bearish is going to be
magenta and really what it's doing right
markets
have to work to get through levels so
for example
if
call 125 250
375 420
take this out up here and let's call it
50 50. you know 720 right
this is the offer right the offer size
that it trades
so you know markets has to work to get
through through
an area right and what that means is as
the market is
moving up okay it's got to get through
these areas right it's got to get to 125
then more at the next level more at the
next level more at the next level even
more at the
at the next level the market works its
way through those
you know these offers right
then that's bullish right because you
know
it took effort by the market on the
markets part to get through these levels
obviously you know this is crude so it's
a bit it's a bit weaker but
that's the idea just as the opposite
would be on the way down
right it's got to work through levels
right say you know if it was going down
if this was
120 then you know 220 and
375 and 550 and
you know 825 right if it's market is
selling off and it's getting through
bigger and bigger levels that's what
sequencing is
okay and again you know depending on the
markets that you're trading
uh what is this bond five minute chart
i don't know if there's any in the bonds
on five minute chart here
right you got the high of the day well
not the high the high is right up here
you're within
two ticks of the high and
sellers are realizing you know what we
can't take it any higher they start
selling it right it's got to eat through
these
strong levels on the way down right it
goes from
241 to 441 783 985
a thousand right it had to work to get
through those levels
okay you know in the e-minis
you know here bearish right bearish
bearish
then it turns around it's got to eat
through these levels bullish bullish as
the market starts going up
there's a little back and forth here you
know but as we're going up more
bullish one you know and this is a big
love big area right obviously it's right
around 3 800 but
you know it 38 double o 50 all the way
up to
two and a quarter it's almost a two
point um
sequencing in there so it's you know
it's quite strong
right so that's what order flow
sequencing is right but you got to use
it with your own analysis as well
not just by oh there's bullet sequencing
i can get long
i mean you could but you know it is best
served in context of the market you know
anything is best served in context of
the market
now ratios okay now the inside the
handouts section
there's a section there there's a
download you can download on order flow
ratios
and it's based on order flow in the bar
right and i'll probably be sending this
out to you on an email
for all you guys that are attending
and what it is is it's going to show you
price defense or price rejection
okay and every bar
every green bar or red bar is going to
have a ratio
okay and bars that are doji candles open
and closed at the same level like this
one here
have no ratio above or below now there's
two colors there's a black
color like this 7.125 and there's blue
37.5
now the blue is actionable the black
ones
are just the normal order flow trading
you know just the normal trading in the
markets that you
you are expecting now
you could adjust the levels okay you
just go
in the settings go to order flows
ratios and where are you here you can
see so price exhaustion
ratio bounds high default i have set to
ratio bounds low i have set to 0.69 now
this will be 30 and above for ratio
bonds high so 30
could be 3 000 it doesn't matter i'm
just a ratio so as long as it's above 30
that's all i care about
now ratio bounds low indicates price
defense now
it's set to 0.69
but it's 0.69 to zero it can't it's not
going to be negative ever the lowest it
could go is zero
okay and
when it's price defense or ratio bounds
low it's telling you there's
supportive buying there's somebody
theoretically defending the price level
they don't want the market to
come down through that level right now
price exhaustion
obviously is going to be a high number
right and so
how i use it how i've always used it
when i
first started noticing this in the
markets is two ways one
i'm looking when we get up to a swing
high right like up here
okay looking for a bearish
i'm looking for a red bar but i'm
looking for the number on top of the bar
okay that's what i'm looking for i'm not
looking for a black number i'm looking
for a blue number
because it's telling me either price
defense or
um price exhaustion so imagine you just
had to move up now i'm seeing exhaustion
okay
i could position myself for a move down
right you got a bit
of a move down here now
let's find a bullish one for you
you know here all right again well this
is a bearish one this is price defense
right we came all the way up here
see the 718 all right you see this
volume up here 718 415 407
obviously the 362 the 402 so this very
good volume up here near the top
all right so i know there's price
defense what happened you know the
market
sold off quick five ten points
okay but that's price ratio bounds low
okay now this is the ratio bounds low
here but again it's
not really the low so i'm not really
looking at that as defense you know
ideally
i'd want to find something you know at a
swing low
this is the low of the day here let me
find another market real quick
okay well this is price exhaustion here
right so we sold off
came down here it's a swing low right i
got the
bullish ratio this is a racial bounds
low 78 because it's above 30.
but really i'm not necessarily diving
into what the ratio number
is i'm just looking for is it blue or is
it black okay
and then i go from there so
i know that this is bullish here right
and you see that nice little move up
okay now i also like using these in
conjunction with
um divergences you know when i got a
delta divergence then you know
i find those divergences to be
especially strong
you know here's stopping volume right
ratio bounds low
right in the low of the day seeing some
heavy volume i mean look at this bar
it's traded
774. the volume that's coming in here is
155. almost half the bar over half the
volume
traded right here at the low so let's
tell me there's support in the market
right and the market goes up goes up to
where an area where i've got
ratio bounds low right the blue number
it's above 30 that's how i know it's a
racial bonds low
and the market sells back to where to
the low of the day and actually goes
lower
right now um
you know that's how you want to be using
it now let's see
crude oil i'll show you
something again you know right up here
right testing the high of the day
you know one tick off the high you get a
ratio bounds low there 40
45 right now i said i like to use it
with
ratio and divergence here's your
divergence here's your ratio
in this case you know the market just
you know it moved down a little bit went
sideways
but i often find in some markets
especially buns and buns is a great
market to trade with order flow
you can get these moves at the high of
the day or the low of the day and they'd
go literally
to from the high of the day to the low
of the day or from the low of the day
back up to the high of the day
you know there's just a divergence but
no ratio right this one failed right
that's why i like to use
ratios with divergence
i just find it a bit more effective way
to use a divergence
in my opinion um
i'm looking for something to show you
guys here just bear with me
uh where am i here
okay so yeah
uh fortunately there's not much there in
the crude let me uh
go here to the e-mini's
you know this what was that that was
eight eleven so the ratio and divergence
but again it started to move there's one
sideways
let me see here yesterday the day before
rather
the day that we're selling off
you know when i need to show you i can't
find any but um you can get the idea
hopefully you know here's price defense
right here
right you come down into the swing low
say racial bounds low in here right
obviously you see the volume
the 269 obviously see even earlier 377
325 so when you're seeing ratios bullish
or bearish
you know bullish ratios coming in at
swing lows or bearish coming in at swing
highs
that's where you want to be paying
attention right because there's
there's something in the market right
and this here is telling you this price
defense obviously
there's nothing to stop you and say i
can't look at this previous bar or this
previous bar
you see oh yeah you know i see some big
bids here
325 377 269 i know there's
support in that market there
right sometimes people get so caught up
in in price that
it uh they're blinded by all the other
information that they're looking at you
know there's
so much information on the chart in
terms of volume
you know what's being traded on the bid
what's being traded on the offer that
you know if you just open your eyes
you can see so much more okay let me
just see if i can't find a
ratio and divergence here then i'll end
it i said you know this market has just
been too crazy lately
um the equities markets you know markets
like
bonds and buns and ultra bonds you know
tend to move a bit
more stable okay here's a ratio and
divergence at the low
came and made a new low before i just
hadn't found this low you know on days i
find that on days where there's a lot of
volatility
and you're trying to buy a low now i'm
not trying to predict a low
i'm letting the order flow tell me that
there's potential low here
on volatile days you tend to get a
little bit of a further push here like
you saw here
before you finally make that move back
up but this is a ratio and divergence
it's telling me there's some support
coming in this market around this 35
area
um you know it just traded down a little
it poked lower
before it turned around and started
going back up
and that's just i'll say unfortunate but
that's just what happens sometimes in
the markets right it's
still searching for it's low so to speak
or it's high um
you know anyway let's move along
prominent points of control
okay a lot of people always wonder
what's this uh why do some bars have
these
things in here like this red or magenta
you know or this
light blue here right what does that
mean well that's a point of control
that matters okay it's a point of
control
that is going to be acting as support
or resistance okay so
you can see here right bearish right
this is magenta now you can
go in here into the chart or sorry into
the indicator settings
and there's three levels of points of
controls prominent points of controls
it's in here
uh plc prominent poc level one level two
level three
now
in markets like nasdaq that have a lot
of price
ranges in a bar this is not going to be
very useful right
this is meant for ideally for markets
that
trade decent amounts of volume right
because again
point of control is the level with the
most volume in a bar
and you know you you're going to want it
to be
i don't know how to say you know a more
compact area
in your trading okay so
when you see them on like e-minis you
know like on wide range bars pay
attention to them
so you can adjust up to three levels
okay of pocs now if i was using a
four-range chart i would only use two
levels of
prominent points of control but what
it's telling you if you see it
like this this is bearish right it's
magenta color magenta is going to be
bearish
again under the settings
you know the reason i developed this is
i used to trade bonds a lot
almost exclusively and i would notice
that certain pocs
where they're appearing in the bar are
bullish or bearish
now i used to use different colors for
each level
but i found it's i'm fine with keeping
them poc level one
two and three the same colors right
because they all have the same meaning
okay now you can adjust the look back
period and the maximum distance in the
bar
from where the poc is going to appear
but
these are my defaults that you get with
the software okay
so this is bearish right mark is moving
up but it's running into some
resistance up here okay let's see if i
can find a bullish one here
it might be a little hard on this market
because it's
moving around these bars got a lot of
price level activity
this was during the day session um
again every bar has a point of control
but not every bar has got a point of
control that's necessarily
going to be a prominent point of control
in something that's going to
act as support or resistance
there's nothing during the day session
there let me go to bonds real quick here
so like here right here bullish bullish
prominent point of controls
here and here okay there was one bearish
one here but
again you're right at the low of the day
when i see points primary point of
control on the edge of the bar
at the low that's very that's even
stronger
but again you want to have some price
activity in the bars
okay let me just change this to a four
range chart really quick
or am i as opposed to a time based chart
because you know really when i look at
bonds
i'm looking at
um look at four range charts
now again if you're on a four range
chart you don't
you only have five price levels so i'm
not going to use the third
prominent point of control right so i'm
going to disable it because really i'm
just looking for
primary point of controls that are going
to appear in the top two or the bottom
two levels
if i have it set to level three on a
four range chart there's only five price
levels
it's going to give me a point of control
in the middle as a prominent point of
control which i don't want
right because that's not a prominent
point of control by definition
but it's it's reading
sort of the the levels in the bar so you
can see right
bullish right this is bearish bullish
bearish
bullish right down here bullish one
right as you closed but look at that
bullish
bearish bullish bearish bullish bearish
um you know this was a bullish one that
failed he was a bearish one
okay here's a couple bullish ones but
then you ran into that bearish
point of control bullish right
bearish bearish bearish
all right well this is 7 30 but
something you know
bearish anyway for it's worth bearish
bearish right up at the high of the day
you move up from the low to the high you
pull
back about 50 a prominent point of
control and you keep going higher
so that's the whole point of prominent
point of controls now the next
point of control is the slingshot point
of control
um we're almost done guys thanks for
bearing with me
it's actually a lot of material covers
you can see you know how robust the
software is
slingshot point of control is a setup
it's a poc setup that appears when the
next bar pulls back versus the previous
bar
then it resumes its initial move now
if case you're wondering right why some
bars
have you know let me find you know the
red all right
the red poc that's the slingshot that's
bearish
or um you know the green is bullish
red is bearish now if in
the settings okay now
just really quick if you have a bullish
if you have a slingshot poc
and the bar also has a prominent poc
it's going to
override the prominent plc because we
find the slingshot is
stronger sign than um
the prominent poc so that's why we have
this color opacity set to 255. you can
see red and green
so it's going to over i don't say
override but
color it in over any prominent point of
control it's because
you know we find it almost an automatic
trade in the sense of
bearish slingshot right okay let the
market confirm you
boom it sold off bullish slingshot okay
market confirms you
boom again it doesn't look like a much
move but the way this market has been
moving
these last few days this is a 10-point
move right here
okay and especially you know on
when a market is starting to trend
seeing them in the direction of the
trend
is is wonderful right here you know
you've seen
when you can combine them with other
things right the the bearish eva
and this bearish slingshot it gives you
a little bit more
confidence in the trade right bear
slingshot
bearish eva right market moves down
here's a bullish one bullish slingshot
but
it goes up and doesn't doesn't do much
here you got another
get another opportunity here you get a
better trade
right as this market's moving up you got
a bearish one here or sorry bullish one
market moves up this one going to stop
you out
but you know when you combine it with
let me just show you
right other things of other forms of
order flow analysis and again i'm just
going to be basic here
eva and a slingshot all right i'm just
going to show you ebas
and a slingshot eba and a slingshot
you know here's a couple evas but no
slingshot i've actually found that when
you get two in a row
it's can be a quite powerful movement
but this time it's already 245 or sort
of running into the cash close there
um you know let's take a look at what is
this crude oil
let's go back friday
um day session
where are we here seven o'clock yet
again i'm just looking for the evas
here's one but no follow-through right
zero follow-through here's one you got
the follow-through in the next bar right
market made
the move up this one
failed okay fine you know not every
single one is going to work out exactly
beautifully here's a eba
and a slingshot now granted you're at
the high of the day
you know trade location wise can the
market go higher yeah of course it can
but in this case you know it went up
then it ran into not a slingshot but
it's a prominent point of control
in a bearish eva
but you know when you start combining
you know sort of the different tools
you'll be amazed at you know some of the
the trade opportunities that you can
take
again i'm just looking right now for
bullish evas
and the slingshot appearing in the same
bar
um anyway let's just move on
the last thing i'll talk about is pocs
in a bar now
you know one of the things that we've
always had in our software was
being able to put more than one poc in a
bar and basically what that means is
you know bars can have
more pocs right it doesn't always have
to be your main poc
and what that means is there's the poc
obviously is the level with the most
volume
but there's a second
poc means the second most volume so
for example i'll just change it to i
don't know orchid
um that would be
plc level two would be the
second most volume in the bar poc level
three
uh gosh i don't know what to color it
i'll just do i'll just do blue
and blue okay so in the regular poc will
just remain black so
plc level 2 is going to be orchid you
know
it's kind of a strange color but i'll
change it to red it's a little easier
well i don't want to change it to red
because that might interfere with your
prominent um
once it could or your slingshot rather
but just let it come up here
and again you know why would you want to
use three levels in a
three poc levels in a bar again you
you gotta realize right what causes
support and resistance is volume
all right volume that's traded so if you
have three pocs in a bar that are sort
of stacked on top of each other now
doesn't have to be stacked in the sense
of one two three it could be one two and
then you know
a skip to the fourth level in the sense
of you know
one poc another poc and then a price
level that's not a poc and then the next
level is a poc um you know that would
you know that's still telling me the
volume is mostly scrunched up at those
levels
now with the addition of the value areas
you know i've sort of moved away from
looking at three
three price levels in a bar because the
value area is going to give me 70
percent of the value area
of the volume in a bar and in some cases
you know i i might be interested in
looking at
um you know 50
of volume in a bar okay so
again it depends on on your trading
style so you know for example
you're like this bar here right this is
your main point of control 3836
the orchid is 38 36 and a half
and the blue is your third point of
control okay
and you know honestly a lot of times you
can get it spread out
in a bar now where is it going to be
effective is
when they're sort of scrunched together
like this here right and we close below
that
you know here they're sort of scrunched
together we close above it
right here it's scrunched together three
price levels
and we close inside but when we close
away from it
right i like to trade in that direction
that's how i've
always used it or when i get two in the
same
you know the poc level one and poc level
two then we break away
and form and lower poc in the bar you
know imagine it it's
like um you know if your studied market
profile you understand a double
distribution day
and you're sort of getting that in here
right as the market direction is moving
down right you got your first
distribution the market moves down you
got your second distribution
okay but again you know the problem
sometimes with looking at multiple pocs
is
you get colorblind but
again you know when i see multiple pocs
sort of lining up at the same levels
like here
here you got one two three four five six
right it's forming a value area now
our value area on the bar sort of
replaces that in the sense
you've seen a bigger picture so i could
see in here right
on these bars just in terms of value
area
between here and here
is your value you know for these bars
look at this trading
right in here then you break out and
close above value now in the past i used
to look at the points at the three
points of controls
and i'd always sort of be you know
scratching my head about a bar like this
where we sort of
probe underneath you know this area
because when you're looking at the
points of controls it's really like
this it's a bit tighter that's why i
like to use
now the value areas because it sort of
gives me a better
understanding of really what's happening
because i always get confused like oh
we're breaking out here
then you sort of revert back in and
trade inside right i would get stuck
sometimes on trades like this whereas
the value area sort of expands it a bit
right but again
you know there are ways i have
strategies of using
three points of controls but i've sort
of now i've kind of moved away a little
bit from it
in the sense that i've got the value
areas
but just really quick
you know on green candles when you're
seeing the three points of controls all
around the same level
at the bottom of the bar that's bullish
like you see here and at a red candle
if all three points of controls are
appearing somewhere near the top of the
bar
that's bearish let me see if i could
find one here for you
um it's got to be a red bar
again you know once controls they don't
always cooperate with you with
the sort of what you're looking for but
when you're when you see it develop
right in front of your eyes
you're gonna notice it like right here
right these three
is the red candle the three points of
control sort of scrunched together
near the top of the bar i've also got um
imbalance reversal i've also got a
bearish ratio tell me
um price defense then
i put it together with what's happening
on the points of controls
yeah okay i know i got price defense i'm
not really looking for the market to go
much higher here
and what happens the market sells off
okay
so that's a lot of information um
i've given you and so i've just
explained
all the different ways and again this is
not all the different ways
there's many other different ways to
analyze order flow now i don't expect
you to jump in and
use them all at once right you got to
trade in context of the market
and the strategies that resonate with
you you know maybe for some of you
you know delta divergence doesn't make
sense or you don't you're not interested
in it but
value area and the expanded value area
works for you or
multiple imbalances together with you
know value area
you know there's so much more you know
and it's like
you know you get a trading software
right like ninjatrader
right off the shelf right and
imagine right you open it up and
you look at the tools involved right now
they got all these things all these
little indicators but they don't really
tell you how to
you know what do you use this for what
do you use well most people know that
what do you use in the column what do
you use mfi what do you use momentum or
the money flow indicator or the ppo or
the pivots
you know they don't even tell you they
just throw it in there everything that's
in
the order flows trader software is there
for a reason right it's there to
help you in your analysis of order flow
right and wise because that's how i
traded with it
when i was still working at jpmorgan
right
at cargill et cetera that's these are
things that i was looking for even
before
there was a footprint chart right i was
always looking for market sweeps in the
market right
or even you know imbalances i don't say
i was looking for imbalances per se but
i was looking for these
areas where big volume would just get
eaten up now i wasn't looking at points
of controls because that wasn't really a
concept back then
and things like ratios and see
when i first discovered the footprint
chart
i started seeing you know in my mind
maybe my mind thought in numbers for
some reason
i'm not you know a mathematician by any
stretch of the imagination
but i understand seeing you know what
would happen in the volume right so
that's how i developed
the ratios um exhaustion prints i would
notice that
at ends of moves what the volume would
look like
right um then as you know i spend more
time
training with the footprint i don't
understand the points of control better
right and why certain points of control
matter while others
just don't matter in the sense that you
know it doesn't necessarily mean
anything in the analysis so
you know all the tools in here are
things that
i use that other traders also use right
so you don't just go out and start
trading every order for a tool that
appears right every signal that appears
you got to put it in context of the
market right and
always trade in context of the market
you know that's what being a trader is
is putting what you're seeing in the
market
in context right it's not just about oh
there's a red arrow
i gotta sell or oh there's a green arrow
i gotta i gotta buy
no you know okay the order flow is
turning bullish
what should i be thinking of doing right
and is
what is starting to see in the order
flow is that
um you know conducive to my
expectations of the market right
so hopefully by now you can see how much
better and easier it is becomes
to trade order flow right when the
software does the analysis
for you so how much do
you know think about it right how much
easier do you think your trading will
become
when you add in order full analysis when
you understand what's happening
in the markets right you know honestly
we tend to make things more complicated
than they really need to be
right i don't say keep it simple you
know kiss
but you know don't over complicate
things especially don't over complicate
trading
and honestly what attracted to me the
order flow
was being able to see who's in control
of the market being able to be
in sync with the market you have to
understand why a market stops and
reverses basically you know i always
wondered why
you know when i was first starting out
in the industry why why does a market
stop at a certain level in reverse
there must be some meaning behind it and
it comes down to the actual trading
right and you know honestly what i
showed you can be done on
any footprint chart if you know what to
look for but honestly i think why did
you
settle for less right you get a software
that's going to do it for you
and process the information that you see
in the time and sales you don't need to
have time and sales up i don't have time
and sales up on my screen
you know i see people with time and
sales you know for what you know it's
just like
a never-ending constant stream of of
prices
and for you know i mean they're not
processing that information they're just
trying to
look cool um you know honestly staring
at a time in sales and i've done it i've
stared at time and sales for
25 years working in the industry i
always had time and sales up there i
don't you know
because you just sort of had to have it
up there people say well this is the
default you like the
people from the cme when they're giving
us globex and even the the frenchies
when they came up with gl right the
right the
the windows based version of globex they
say oh you got yours time and sales so
you gotta have it up so you know
okay i gotta have it up but for what
right you have things on your screen
that you're gonna
help you understand
what's happening in the market so
hopefully
hopefully it's past two hours actually
you'll find it's been time well spent
and i covered a lot of stuff honestly i
can't cover every single thing
i do have weekly 60-minute training
sessions for
users of the software but if you're
interested in the software again you
know i've explained it what it is
and what it does it's really like having
a computer plugged into my brain um
and i'm not trying to brag or anything
but really what i look for in the market
right and what i've always looked for in
the market
okay so that's what my software does um
it does analysis for you so it's going
to make your training a bit easier
right but again having software is one
thing you have to know how to use it
all right you gotta know what to look
for in the order flow so i don't just
give you software it's gonna go figure
it out on your own good luck
um you know i provide a lot of education
right i give you access to my trading
course
it's 20 lessons in there it's about 15
hours of video instruction
right i give you access to the order
flows inner circle video series there's
another
bunch of videos in there um you know on
all different ways to analyze the order
flow
and i always expect you to just go watch
a bunch of videos for the rest of your
life you know
you also want to be watching the markets
live you know and
putting what you're learning into
use right if you were i'll
add that up together honestly it's it's
quite expensive it's sixteen hundred
dollars honestly i don't think it's
expensive i mean
you know something that can transform
your life is can you put a price on it
but again you know it's one thing to
learn from books and videos
but you really want to have you know
constant
interaction right you want to have some
weekly interaction with me that you know
hey this is what you know we're looking
at now in the markets this is what i saw
today
so i have a weekly group training
session right that's live
every tuesday night 7 p.m central time
they're all recorded there's actually
100 and i think 11 now
this is an old picture it's like 111
sessions recorded again i don't expect
you to watch them all but
um you know if you miss one you could
catch it
so you know again and other people want
to charge you extra for that you know it
boggles my mind you know there's i see
software people's
selling software for whatever price you
know 300 a month right they want to
charge you forever
and then oh well we'll train you how to
read the order flow for another thousand
bucks and what that's the ripoff
my mind um you can't get all this right
software
training we live training it's just a
one-time payment
749. i hate these softwares that charge
you forever
you know and it's like even you know
they're charging you two
three hundred dollars a month you know
to your card
and you even cancel the card and you're
still getting charged
you know it's like i don't know what you
know probably when you die you'll still
be getting charged
um you know my software is just cheap i
say cheap it's inexpensive it's
affordable
right 7.49 you know again you know yeah
i get people saying oh you should charge
more like yeah
i could but you know honestly i'd rather
reach out to more people
um you know because you know people tell
me you know they're struggling you know
and they're trading you know they want
to get better
and you know i understand that you know
because i know it was like when i first
started in the industry that's why i got
started in this industry because i
wanted to be a better trader that's why
i started on the floor
as a runner so that i can learn more
about trading
all right and like you know i took to it
like
a fish to water fortunately and you know
i started meeting the right people and
my career took off and i applied what i
was learning right that's what you got
to do is you got to apply what
you'll learn again you know other people
have been saying you know great things
just
you know it's there are people that say
negative things you know there are
people out there
you go on the internet you type my name
in people when he's a scammer or
whatever
you know who who are these people
right some of these are are my
competitors honestly
um you know there's somebody yeah you
know i get people
you know i release things either
indicators or course
and there's people that buy it and then
they refund it
okay like a course they buy it then two
days later
they refund it okay i thought they do
that over and over
right i guess one guy bought five of my
indicators
then within two days three days he would
re you know
do a chargeback i mean okay you know if
it's really so
bad why why you keep buying it you know
yeah i've had to block people you know
then people you know they even get
mean you know honestly some of these
emails but you know
anybody that's asked for a refund has
gotten it you know there's times where
paypal has had to do an investigation
because sometimes people are serial
refunders
they think that's me but it's actually
on paypal's part you know paypal also
does their due diligence
so when people you know buy things over
and over
and then they ask for a refund and
paypal finally opens the investigation
into them
they get bent out of shape and they
write nasty things
okay fine but i get all these i get a
lot of messages from people saying you
know your
trading has your courses or you know
your software has really made a
difference and that's why i do it
right you know the the tire kickers
you know these people that's just a
small percentage
really you know and it does get over
initially
it gets under my skin for a minute or
two but
you know what these people you know
they'll never be successful
right because they don't want to put in
the time i could tell if someone buys
the software then two days later i can't
make it to work i don't understand it
well you haven't even spent time to try
to learn it i try to keep it as simple
as possible
right i showed you how simple it is to
load up a chart
right and if people can't even take the
time to
try to you know spend some effort to
watch a video on how to set it up or
something yeah
you can't please everybody but people
that do get the software
and use it and put in the effort
are like converts you know i don't say
it's a cult but you know they're
they find that the results are amazing
right they
they say you know i don't know how i
ever you know i don't like why did i
ever
trade without understanding order flow
so i gotta do is go to orderflows.com
off three scroll down
go to um here
press that button it's going to take you
to paypal paypal process is it again
it's just
7.49 it's a one-time payment you're not
going to get charged in the future for
an upgrade like i said we're on our
third upgrade that's why it's called off
three
because this is our our well the first
version is just off
then the second upgrade the first
upgrade rather than
this is the second but it's the third
version of loft and you get
the upgrades for free i don't i didn't
charge anybody when we moved from
ninjatrader 7 to ninjatrader 8
you got upgraded for free right and if
you're on the old version of off 2
send me an email all right i've pretty
much got everybody converted already
over to off 3
but there are some people that are still
on off using the previous version
we don't charge you for those upgrades
you know when we make big changes in the
software
and we release it again we don't charge
it for that
that's for the order flows trader
software now i have other indicators
which are separate
and that just reads one part of the
order flow now
again you got to get off off your ass
and do something right i
i've been emailing you people email me
for the last several years
asking questions about the software etc
and i'm just like you know yeah i answer
them but at the same time it's like
well when are you gonna get off the pot
so to speak and take some action
right it's better to take imperfect
action than than no action
right because you could do nothing for
the next year or two years
and stay where you are right that's not
where you want to be
maybe you could try to figure it out on
your own right but
yeah you know you're going forward but
you know instead of understanding
where things go you know
it's not going to be as good right what
you want to do is you want to put the
ball in the back of the net right you
want to score
and that's where i come in
right because you're going to learn how
to read the order flow better okay
but again you gotta take action right
you got to
understand what motivates you and why
you want to do it
right oh you know i'm unhappy with my
job i hate my boss
whatever okay what are you going to do
to improve yourself right i had to make
a big
shift in my career to get started on the
trading floor
right i went from making you know when i
was 20 years old i was making 35 000
a year in a job i said you know what but
yeah i don't want to do this
the rest of my life you know i want to
get into trading and that's why i left
the truth
my you know when you're 30 when you're
20 years old making 35 000
that's you think you know you're king
but i realized
what's my max potential right that's why
i left that job
when i was you know at that age and got
started on the floor we're
running for dean winter at 5.25 cents an
hour
which at that time was considered a lot
most of the places charged paid your
minimum wage
actually like four dollars 375.
but anyway you know i have to make that
choice because what motivated me was a
better life
right now what motivates me is my family
right being able to go on vacation
whenever we want right to do nothing i
don't want to work today okay fine
you know i just want to veg out and
binge netflix you know some shows or
something okay i can't do that
right trading gives me that freedom you
gotta find out what motivates you
what you want to do with your life now i
got a special bonus
again you get the software it says for
investors expo but this is uh
you'll also get it you've got the
orderful playbook right which is my
um course that i did a
year ago um i think it's a fantastic
course
i think it's one of my underrated
courses but i'll give you that for free
normally i sell for 297. if you go to
orderflows.complaybook.html you can see
it's for sale there for 297. and people
still buy it separately
um but again you know i want you guys to
get going right do something with your
life right
get started so again what you'll get is
the workflows trader software
right this the upgrades that come with
the order flows trader
software will also be you know it's free
i i want to put a value on that because
it's it's
i give it to you the trading course
the inner circle video series the
playbook right
plus live weekly group training you know
we've been doing it for over two years
right we were the first
people to really do it now we're
starting to see other software vendors
doing it as well right because you know
honestly you know you get software you
want to be able to
understand it right and it's not just
the point of you know playing email tag
you have the opportunity every week to
come in there
ask your questions you know say you've
been trying to reach me you can't reach
me for whatever reason maybe your email
goes to my spam
okay fine at least you know i'm there
every week
right that you can you could say hey
mike you missed my email or
you just put your message in there say
mike you know i need a new license token
or something you know my
at a bios upgrade or something and
ninjatrader gave me a new machine id
that's fine that's what that's why i do
it okay and again it's just a one-time
payment this price is actually going up
a bit later this month um
but it's still you get involved now for
7.49
again i think that's a that's a terrific
it's a terrific deal
you know honestly um again i see people
charging
thousand dollars 999 for trading
instruction for what
right and then they just teach you stuff
that they learn from watching other
people
trade or their videos you know at least
here you get it from me and you get live
sessions as well so again you gotta get
started go to orderflows.com
off three